we tend to think of tv and film
productions as enjoying bottomless
budgets but that just isn't the case
whether they were greedy actually
deserved more money or were trying to
get out of a role these actors asked for
a raise and found themselves fired
for three years the teen comedy lizzie
mcguire ruled the disney channel roost
with hilary duff in the titular role
unfortunately the success of 2003's the
lizzie mcguire movie marked the
beginning of the end for the fictional
teen sweetheart that same year
entertainment weekly spoke to susan duff
hillary duff's mother and manager she
said that disney ended negotiations for
a film sequel when she asked for a
promised bonus to be paid immediately
she also told ew that disney was trying
to shortchange her daughter to continue
on the lizzie mcguire series apparently
they offered only 35 000 per episode
even though they knew she was being
offered six figures by outside parties
in the end it seems that disney couldn't
give her what she wanted as both the tv
series and the plans for a movie sequel
ended that's okay
i don't want it in 2019 news broke that
a revival series was being planned for
disney plus with duff back in mcguire's
shoes but by the end of 2020 duff told
fans on her instagram that the plan
series wouldn't happen in 1985's back to
the future crispin glover played marty
mcfly's dad george mcfly however the
star was not only absent for 1989's back
to the future part 2 and its sequel
except for shots recycled from the first
film but his disappearance indirectly
led to a lawsuit glover was apparently
unhappy with the script for back to the
future 2 and demanded the same salary as
lead michael j fox 1 million dollars to
return in 2012 glover told the av club
that this was a lie and that he was
offered 150 000 for the sequel he
claimed that it was around half the
amount offered to leah thompson and tom
wilson who had similar sized roles he
also said that when he tried to
negotiate the offer was actually
decreased by 25 000
the following year on opie and anthony
glover said he did express issues with
the script and implied that the studio's
supposedly low offer was punishment for
his questions with glover out jeffrey
weissman stepped into the role and he
was outfitted with a mold made from
glover's face the mold turned out to be
much more expensive than the filmmakers
expected in 1990 glover sued the
producers of back to the future part 2
for using his likeness without
permission the producers settled for a
reported 760 thousand dollars
in 1988's die hard and its 1990 sequel
bruce willis's john mcclane takes out
the bad guys pretty much on his own but
in 1995's die hard with a vengeance he
gets a sidekick in the form of
electrician zeus carver in a 2020
episode of the rewatchables podcast
quentin tarantino said the part of
carver was written specifically with
lawrence fishburne in mind he added that
fishburn believing he had the producers
over the proverbial barrel demanded a
one million dollar payday but then came
the 1994 cannes film festival where one
of the producers was impressed with
samuel l jackson's performance in pulp
fiction as anyone who's seen die hard
with a vengeance knows jackson took the
part of carver and the producers escaped
fishburn's barrel or so they thought in
july 1994 before die hard with a
vengeance made its way to theaters
fishburn hit the production company with
a lawsuit for breach of contract the
lawsuit was settled three years later
for 750 000 a couple bucks shy of what
fishburn would have gotten if the
producers had agreed to his initial
asking price
the action star clown car that is the
expendables franchise boasts names like
sylvester stallone arnold schwarzenegger
jet li terry crews jason statham and
many more of course starting with 1988's
die hard bruce willis entered the
pantheon of cinematic action heroes
fittingly willis enjoys a cameo in
2010's the expendables along with a
larger role in the 2012 sequel the
expendables 2. but while most fans
expected willis to reprise the role of
church for 2014's the expendables 3 it
wasn't to be in august 2013 sylvester
stallone announced in all caps a major
cast change on twitter sharing willis
out harrison ford in great news been
waiting years for this by the following
day the hollywood reporter was claiming
willis's exit from the franchise was due
to a huge paycheck demand according to
the source cited willis was offered
three million dollars for four days work
he allegedly demanded a pay bump to four
million one million per day the source
added that ford was cast within 72 hours
of willis's exit
to this day plenty of fans named the
late sir sean connery as their favorite
actor who played the sexy spy james bond
however the producers who negotiated
with connery may have felt differently
connery's first turn as double 07 came
with 1962's dr no and he played the
charming secret agent in four more
feature films before demanding a lot
more compensation by the time connery
starred in 1967's you only lived twice
he was being paid 750 000 plus a 25
share of merchandising however
apparently the actor was reportedly
bored with playing the super spy and
demanded 1 million dollars to appear in
the next bond film plus a percentage of
the gross producers tried to use george
lazenby as a bargaining chip but connery
didn't budge
and so the producer said goodbye to
connery and lazenby made his one and
only appearance as james bond in 1969's
on her majesty's secret service
according to the documentary becoming
bond in spite of negative reviews for
ladies and bey's only bond film the
actor said he was offered a contract for
six more movies he apparently turned
them down on his agent's advice without
lazenby united artists lured connery
back to the world of espionage with the
1.25 million offer for 1971's diamonds
are forever
since the early second season of the hit
zombie apocalypse drama the walking dead
maggie ree played by lauren cohan was a
staple of the series however in season 9
maggie left the relative safety of the
hilltop colony to join up with a
different band of survivors at least
that was the narrative reason for her
absence behind the scenes however
kohan's contract renegotiations for
season 9 hadn't gone the way she'd hoped
cohen refused to settle for less and she
was written out of the show all this
time running from walkers
you forget what people do cohan went on
to star in the abc action dramedy
whiskey cavalier according to cohan in
spite of early reports that her only
concern was money she already had one
foot out the door before contract
negotiations broke down in a 2018
discussion with andy cohen on radio andy
cohan said she'd already been looking to
explore comedy and happier fare talking
to ew cohan mused eight years is a long
time to spend in one character
thankfully for maggie fans the character
was written off but not killed and in
october 2019 news broke that kohan would
be returning to the walking dead as a
series regular for the 11th and final
season in fact cohen showed up early in
a recurring role toward the end of
season 10.
in 1980 abc's three's company was one of
the most successful sitcoms on
television the story about two women and
one man living together as roommates and
a santa monica apartment was a hit
suzanne summers who played the
voluptuous and ditzy chrissy snow
thought a pay raise was an order however
her efforts ended with her getting
booted off the show the hollywood
reporter revisited the story of summer's
firing in 2015 saying that summers was
getting paid 30 thousand dollars per
episode while co-star john ritter was
bringing home 150 000 when summers asked
for more abc offered her a bump of 5 000
per episode but the actress stood her
ground and demanded the same amount
ritter was receiving after abc refused
summer's demand the actress missed the
tapings for season five's third and
fourth episodes and was soon fired
before this happened summer's manager
and husband alan hamill was allegedly
warned earlier that year abc had bowed
to pressure and given raises to penny
marshall and cindy williams who at the
time were the leads of laverne and
shirley hamel said a friend with
connections at abc called and told him
that abc made an example of summers to
end talk of any more big paydays to
leading women
when marvel fans first met james rhodey
rhodes who would later become the
avenger known as war machine it was
terence howard playing the character but
in 2010's iron man 2 it was don cheadle
in the role and cheedle would continue
to play rhodey for the rest of the
character's appearances in the marvel
cinematic universe howard wasn't happy
with his ousting from the mcu and for a
while he was pretty brazen about letting
people know about it in 2013 on watch
what happens live howard told andy cohen
that when it came time to make iron man
2 marvel only wanted to pay him 1 8th of
what they owed him he also added that
when he reached out to co-star robert
downey jr for help he was ghosted two
years later howard told rolling stone
that he'd volunteered to take a 1
million dollar pay cut to get downey
cast as tony stark in 2008's iron man
however marvel disagreed with howard's
story in 2017 howard returned to watch
what happens live and said he and downey
were friends once more he also claimed
he was drunk when he'd appeared on the
show in 2013 and blamed his inebriation
for what he'd said he stopped short
however of saying his initial version of
events was false
the first role that made critics take
real notice of robert duvall was that of
tom hagan he was the shrewd but over
cautious consigliere of the corleone
crime family in 1972's the godfather
duvall earned his first academy award
nomination for his work in the film and
he reprised the role in 1974's the
godfather part 2. but while hagen
survives the events of the first sequel
he's nowhere to be found in 1990s the
godfather part 3. instead we learn hagen
has passed away in the years between the
two stories speaking to charlie rose in
2004 duvall said he left tom hagan
behind not only because he wasn't
offered enough money but because someone
else got way too much duvall told rose i
said i would work easily if they paid al
pacino twice what they paid me that's
fine but not three or four times which
is what they did in 2010 duvall told
reuters he had no regrets about not
appearing in the film since as many
critics and fans have agreed it wasn't
as good as the first two
when nbc's political drama the west wing
premiered in 1999 it was looking like
rob lowe's sam seabourn would be a main
character but over the course of three
seasons seabourn's role on the show
diminished finally a season 4 storyline
was written to facilitate his departure
though he returned in a recurring role
in the show's final season according to
cbr roblo's departure from the west wing
wasn't just because he had trouble
getting the show to pay him more money
instead it was because he was the only
lead actor in the series who couldn't
get more money while many of lowe's
co-stars had their salaries doubled
since the beginning of the series his
had reportedly remained the same for
example while cnn put lowe's
compensation at 75 000 per episode
martin sheen was receiving 300 000 per
episode in an official statement low
released in july 2002 he said that he
was grateful to have been a part of the
series however it had been increasingly
clear for a while that there was no
longer a place for sam seabourn on the
west wing check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you